- Un lavabo à la main,
en allusion à l'expression
anglntntntntntntntntntntntntntne
à l'idée que c'est lui,
le nouveau patron de Twi
Elon Musk n'en est pas
à une extravagance près.
BRUNO GUGLIELMINETTI,vavavavava.
Et ça veut dire tout, là.
Ça veut dire ndndndnd ménage,
l'efficacité, puis les profits.
- Ça veut aussi dire, pour Elon
Musk, la liberté de l'oiseau,
44 milliards de dollars, tout
en montrant la porte au PDG
de Twitter et au directeur
financier et juridique. Il seses
d'utilisateurs, qui se classe
au 14e rang ulululularité dans
le monde et qui n'atteint que
21 millions de consommateurs.
- On veut rendre ça plus
Ça, c'est un message très
concret qu'il envoie. Après,
s s s suite, bien là, ça va
passer par d'autres choses.
Il va falloir rendre la plate-
forme, beaucoup plus
pas étonononononononononononono.
- Le retour espéré des
publicitaires, mais également de
Donald Trump, qui se réjouit que
bonnes mains. Sur sa plate-forme
Truth Social, il écrit quelululr
les fous de chchchche radicale
qui détestent véritablement
Mais est-cetetetetour
de l'extrême droite?RORORORORORe
- La symbolique de dire qu'on va
rouvrir Twitter, finalement,
à quelqu'un qui répandait,
pendant lafofofofofofofofofofofé
une partie de manifestants de
tenter de renverser le Capitole
au mois de janvier... Alors,
on
de la science et des faits ne va
pas diminuer sur Twitter.
- Il faudra voir comment,à l'in,
on va modérer tous ses propos.
Parce que c'est une chose
expression, mais est-ce qu'on
est en faveur de la diffamationa
désinformation?
C'est là où Elon Musk va être
testé dans son l
- Celui qui a conquis le
l'espace avec Tesla et SpaceX
se lance à présent cocococonquêe
de nos écrans. L'homme le plus
riche du monde avait annoncé,
n'était qu'un premier pas
l l l la création d'une super
application portant le nom de X.
Ici Yasmine Khayat,adadadadadal